and that was just mouth and that was
just mob that was just mob so how was
that I was instant action submit or
action simple submit or action and I was
prepared to go to the deaf to do it
getting shot in my eye
prove that
Point Blank ranging that son Posh yeah
proves that I don't care I didn't care I
didn't care I said do your job you mug
do your job let me shot me I said do
your job again
and welcome to this episode of
extraordinary lives a lad Bible podcast
we're joined today by Marvin Herbert uh
Marv it's great to have you in the
studio we've done a couple of pieces
with you previously and you're a
fascinating individual but for any new
viewers who haven't heard of you could
you briefly describe who you are and
what you're known for
all right my name's Marvin Herbert
um
I'm known for living a life of
barbaric and sunny I am a led a life or
crime from the age of 11 years of age up
to 42 raging from everything from petty
crime up to murder I've been under
investigation for murder I'm robbery
robbery stabbing shootings theft arm
robbery and um
taking them driving away actual bodily
harm gbh
section 18 section 29 everything you can
ever imagine being arrested for but
sexual offenses is my journey my story
My Reality you know it's a very clear
introduction
um and I'd love to start right at the
beginning if it's okay with you because
obviously you're someone as you've just
said who lived a very uh unusual life
with huge ups and huge downs but where
did it start what was childhood like for
you
[Music]
[Applause]
my childhood was
normal to me
if I'm being honest
it wasn't the childhood
the first times I would ask me that
question I think I found a live Bible
actually said I had a normal upbringing
of
obviously because of my journey I'm sort
of transforming into a different person
so now I've realized that I never had a
child
foreign
[Music]
memories as a as a baby planting a
swimming pool but after that it's just
been anger
it's just been hate
frustration
it's been a life I wouldn't wish on
anybody if I'm being honest
it's a life I wouldn't wish on anybody
now is different but the life I've led
to get me where I'm today old and I wish
for anybody I really wasn't and even
talking about it nowadays off it just
I can't talk about it without being
angry or emotional
so depending on where I am we'll
determine how I act so when I'm with the
street and I talk about my life I have
to be angry to talk about it so they can
see the anger that got me where I am but
I'm around normally
emotionally it's weird
but I think that's because I'm becoming
normal and I have empathy now which I
never used to have you know so
yeah
I'm trying to be the best human being I
can be now because of what I've been
through I mean and it's just
crime just doesn't bite
crime just causes so much bye
[Applause]
would you rather I didn't ask questions
about that period of your life well you
know what I need it yeah this is what
life's all about and this is what these
kids have got to see like I'm a figure
of power and strength about Resort into
this when I'm talking about my reality
is a mature man so it's not anything I
want to hide it's the only thing I need
to be embarrassed about
it hurts being that man it hurts being
that man
or
it hurts
being that man I was if that makes sense
the pain that I've caused myself my fab
[Applause]
[Laughter]
it's kind of now you realize oh
and that's the thing these kids are
going to realize it's not a joke it's
not a joke and look I'm 51. I'm a figure
of power and strength in the gym you
can't trouble me in the gym you can't
trouble in the ring you can't trouble me
emotionally but when I talk about the
pain I've caused and the life that I've
LED it hurts you know uh now I'm proud
of being a man or him I really am proud
of getting through that journey and
coming up against him no good grooming
parasite paracidual adults that use
young men to prosper how they hate them
like with a passion so now I use that
height and that passion to drive me
towards changing the narrative for these
youngsters behind me which is which is
amazing and I'm like I'm I'm it's an
amazing story and I really want to get
on to how you've got to do that but I'm
wondering if it's okay with you if to
help people understand your journey I
can ask you a few details
you're the biggest platform in the world
right now for what needs to be said so I
need to hear what needs to be asked and
I need to answer them as honestly as I
can so I
who I am and what I've been through so
if it hurts it has to hurt okay if I
have to show the world how much
I'm big enough to do that okay yeah all
right all right big enough to get
involved in established shooting and
robbing and doing all sorts of
pretending it didn't matter he didn't
care I didn't care I didn't care then I
didn't care all right I care now let's
let's find out how someone ends up in
that position so let me ask you when you
say your childhood was one of
basically anger frustration what what
does that look like basically like I
said my hand got burned by my dad at
eight years of age so I think of looking
at a man you love the man you worship
the mad you want to become then you just
you can't explain unless someone does
that to you you can't explain the power
or the pain and the the frustration it
causes and it was just something that
got embedded in me and I just I couldn't
be hurt like that and why why did he
burn your hand because on Nick the
starbar and a Wrigley spearming gum and
the thought detectives brought me home
and he wanted to make an example of me
however now we know now my dad was just
trying to keep me away from what he knew
was coming what he knew I was going to
become and what he knew
was there and he was frightened
as much as any man would be and he
didn't know how to deal with
such a confident powerful individual and
that's all I was I was just too
confident and too powerful for my own
good and it led me to where I got to and
now I use that strength and power for
good reasons and good good cause so
I'm glad I was that guy I'm glad I am
that guy and I'm glad I've got that
strength so
I'm glad he beat me the way he beat me
because it wouldn't have made me the man
I'm today however it's painful because
and then when you say about the
he did that to you he burned your hands
um was that a sort of like one-off event
or had your childhood been no there's no
that was the second time he'd done it he
done it when I set the house on fire
Christmas right I said the house on fire
Christmas firing Nicole me and my
brother and then and then that happened
and then it was just whatever happened
we just got the extreme amount of
punishment and that was just what I
could never understand with him but then
I wouldn't be here
I would be as fortunate as I am today 12
as many people so I thank my journey for
doing what he'd done because of the
choices I made um
and were you exposed to criminality at a
young age yeah yeah my dad was a drug
dealer high level so all the drugs all
the money we see in the house was just
there forever that was all it was I see
guns from an early age yeah it seemed
like weapons from an early agency my Dad
tried to cut my mom's head off I see my
dad beat my mum we got bad we got B and
like we got beaten with belts whips like
everything you get it with we got hit
with apart from penetrate with weapons
so we never got stabbed but we got hit
with pan but no you got beaten you got
yeah in the 70s and 80s like nowadays
the kids don't get it because back in
the 70s everyone got a beating but we
got extreme meetings so that was normal
for you like you hadn't had anything
else that was normal even the teachers
used to beat us up like if I just look
at my dad you can get the belt from a
teacher in school did you get it so a
teacher could get take his belt off and
whip you with a belt and not get Nick
for it God facts wow right a teacher
could weigh you in in school and you
couldn't get nicked and then everyone's
in the late 80s everyone started
fighting against the teachers and then
people I'd made a tune hey teacher leave
them kids alone because kids was abusing
kids the teachers was abusing all the
kids forever and it's only since the New
Millennium now that it's all stopped
like a lot of my peers from the criminal
fraternity have been sexually abused but
a lot of them have been sexually abused
hence the reason why they're insane I
got physically abused hence the reason
why I became physically insane John
stands are mentally insane so everything
has a reason and everybody's got to be
accountable for their reasons and their
choices and everything they go through
you know I remember you talking before
do you mind telling us a story about
because there was a turning point wasn't
there when you basically decided you'd
have enough of the physical abuse at
home with your dad
ah you know what I just gotta bang it as
well you know
um I've got that painted two days ago
okay yeah yeah so basically what
happened is I've been Nick and puff off
my dad for years and my brothers
everybody
um basically by the time I was 14 15 I
was nicking Parcels from delivery Vans
right so Brands would deliver
um wholesale stuff to
um the streets the High Street shops
like the JD the woods and then we used
to Rob them delivery Vans and then
basically wearing my ass one day
um going through a lot of stock with
Nick and my dad turned up to get
whatever he left in my house with my mum
and obviously it weren't there so he
started beating my mom because he
thought my mum because my mum was a bit
of a a flyer she'd done she was a the
mama was a road woman she lived on the
road she lived through the road she
worked on her own she'd done everything
so money's come on me for my mom and
nicked it so he's beating my mama so me
and my power's in my room
and we can hear my mom getting beaten up
so I had to bang it and I've got it now
I wish I'd have bought it now damn right
so what I'm gonna do I'll take a video
of that and send it okay so you can show
it I'll show you all right yeah so now
I've seen the paint on the floor so I'll
send it my power pick up a weapon up
here and I'll be going through him we'll
do my dad we've got to do him he's gonna
kill my mum so I've run down the stairs
I'm running the kitchen I'm putting
played my applications now touched my
mom again I'll [__] kill you I mean
touch my mom again and I'll kill you and
he was like he backed up like that as
he's backed up I sort of pushed him and
then he stepped back and I saw before
his asshole's gone he's gone and I
pushed him back and I've got him to that
outside the house and then he's off and
then based yeah how old are you here um
I think 14 or 14 I was 14 yeah when he's
gone
and this is why I've got the bayonet
back right so now I've got to go one
step further because my dad's a big man
in um North London right a place called
Church Road he used to do a lot of
business and it was very predominant
with um black on black crimes and
violence so basically there was a lot of
heat in the area so basically I thought
I want to make an example so I went and
got a gun off my mate yeah which was a
replica but it was a 44 all-matting cult
I put it down the back of my trousers
and when I've gone and when I took it
about to leave my bayonet as a deposit
imagine that right so I've got a thing
as a deposit got him
pulled a gun out and basically put in my
dad and said it never comes to my house
and yeah no I was talking to my dad and
one of his mates says that so I pulled
it out and put it on his mate I said I
said oh [__] blow your head off and
then basically I just said mother come
back to my house again at the top of my
mind I'm gonna blow your head off and
that was kind of like the turning point
in my
sort of growth as a man I actually felt
like the most powerful man on the planet
after that night did he not come back no
never came back we spoke I still
surprised my dad but to me he was only a
mug then right I mean like he's a mug
he's a mug he's a mug that's in mind
he's a mug he's a wanker he's his
[__] went but when you went into that
room with the replica
and it was a room of adults who
presumably were involved in the game
that you've been like looking at when
you were growing up were you not afraid
no no no
no you don't he's kind of mad when
you're insane you don't get scared of
nothing you know like you just you I was
more
my intention was to impress more than
right suffer so I didn't care I had to
impress everybody that I was doing this
so I was I was making a stand and I've
made an impact and I've done it from
when I was a kid and I'm doing it now
that's why I got to Downing Street
imagine that I got to an industry how's
that possible yeah do you understand
what I'm saying I reach for the stars
mate not the moon okay so you so
basically you were going in there just
thinking like
okay yeah I want to let my dad know I
want to let my dad know I want to let
him know I've got this and I had another
toy in case he went pear-shaped you I
mean but I was prepared for it okay so
then you go back home you're 14 did you
say yeah how did things progress after
that lovely I was going back into drugs
and got back in Robin and got went up
the ladder and started robbing more
doing more I was a man in the ass I fed
my mum fed my brothers fed my sisters
and then I saw fell out fill it in and I
realized she was my brothers and sisters
because everybody made different choices
in life to do different things and I
agreed with some of them didn't agree
with some of them call me some I never
got me some but I've apart from the
females of my family I've patiently
stabbed and shot at and cut and punched
and chopped my brothers and sisters none
of my sisters but I beat my scissors up
as a young man I'm not proud of that but
I'm not going to hide behind the man I
want I mean I I beat one of my sisters
up two of my sisters up
unforgivably enough and then I've
stabbed my brothers I've actually been
just nuts it was just our normal
violence was our normal when you didn't
agree with us it was violence and that
was it we all accepted violence when we
were kids and we all speak now apart
from one sister I speak to all my
brothers and sisters apart from one you
know I mean and what was your what was
the what was your goal at that age was
it just to survive just being a man were
you looking at getting higher I need to
get as much money as possible to get
back out right I need to get as much
money as possible to get back out I need
to be out of all of this I need to be
away from all this that's why I moved up
that's why I ended up in Spain on my own
I never went on and around the world on
my with a game I was marveling over on
his own I went and faced every adversity
on my own I felt every danger on my own
I felt every occasion on my own every
bit of fear on my own I'd dealt with
every situation on my own there ain't a
man on this planet who's backed me up
there's not a man on this planet it's
backed me up today and there's that's
how it is I wasn't that guy I wasn't
that guy I wasn't that guy so you've
told us stories before uh one of the
ones I wanted to ask you about again was
if you could retell the story about is
it the Camden roundhouse is that where
it happened
yeah there's a story about one of your
mates who got beaten up or something
like that yeah it was about six days
about 17 I am 16 17 17 18 it was
because after this event I got arrested
for trying to shoot a bands up trying to
figure what's up
this this excavator happened
and then the week the weekend or the
night after this event I was arrested
for trying to shoot a bands out how old
are you guys
um 17 or 18 right sorry yeah yeah so now
I've got out when I was 19 I was 17 or
18 or possibly 19 I could have been 19.
um basically there was a few kids around
our area we used to sell drugs and take
drugs and party a couple of kids have
bought a couple of Moody well bought a
couple of these off my mate but that was
a bit trippy so they wanted their money
back and because they wouldn't get their
money back they beat up on me and then
they just escalated and escalated and
escalated and escalated over the space
of a year and then after a year they
started attacking my friends mums and
friends houses and I was just like what
no and then basically I was driving down
the road one night and someone flagged
me down and said you know them in the
round ass I was like what are you
talking about he said they're all in
there I said oh he said every single one
of them
we went and got
um some ammonia a baseball bat and a
knife and we went in
and basically how many of you how many
of you three of us and how many of them
I don't know 15 14 I don't know 10 12 14
I don't know those are five and then
with their girlfriends on unfortunately
enough one of my friends girlfriends who
was there on the night she's got a big
split on her head because I've as I've
gone like that with a baseball bat I've
caught her in the head so I do apologize
and I've actually forgot your name so
I'm not saying it with any with any form
of non regret I'll regret the knife
James and so as I've gone like that it's
Buster red open and then the people that
we was targeting got put on the floor
and then one of my friends stabbed them
all up and um so how does that work so
you get in there the three of you
they're 14 15 of them we blinded them
first well so you threw him on your over
them threw them on your over and then I
targeted the ones we needed with the
baseball bat and then the other side and
come in and prep their legs so they
couldn't get half a month and then we
just spoke to them in the way to letting
them know that it continues then we'll
go one step further and people won't be
getting up off the floor
how do you
I mean to someone like me the thought of
three of you
as like quite a young man still going in
against affirm
15 people that just sounds absolutely
terrifying like how do you actually
manage to keep your mind going through
an event like that I don't know I really
don't know it is your regular comments
of 14 people 15 people 12 people I've
been stabbed up both my lungs have been
punched and I had another fighting
kentish town in a place called poshnosh
when 13 or 14 boys from hoxton Over East
London come in the bar and start taking
the bees I'll try to calm it down and
they didn't want to listen and it kicked
off eventually
um four of them got ended up in
intensive care with head injuries and I
ended up getting stabbed and cut and I
both my lungs up 100 and I've got taken
to hospital but it was a decent fight we
all got beaten up and everyone got
opened up cut up and I was fighting on
my own and one of my friends got thrown
through the window
and then yeah I walked out of there well
I walked out of there and then when I
walked back in I collapsed yeah I walked
out and said come on you yeah and the
rest of them run up the road there's
four or five of them on the floor or
three or four of them on the floor and
then basically I collapsed the lungs I
wouldn't breathe and I collapsed you
know I ended up down in the hospital
three days and back out again I remember
you said once before actually when we're
talking about The Roundhouse thing
before you said you had like some signs
about like when you went in there to to
to fight those guys you had like if you
rubbed your hair it meant do you
remember this oh that's right
when we walk in right I'm here my mate
saying Melvin makes that yeah so as one
walks in one's wearing a bandana glasses
but shuffles everything here so when
he's in place now and he knows who's
there he rubs his head which means it's
sweet that means it's a go-go it's a
go-go so one of my mates gone over there
and made sure the ones that we need are
there so we're on the other side of the
Dance Floor look at him as he's gone
like that we know they're there right we
know they're there we know they're there
so what he does as we're walking towards
him he moves over in front of the people
that we're going to attack so then what
he does when we get to him he just steps
aside then we just splash him all up
with the ammonia and then you know
you've got all the people in front of
him that's where they are so you Splash
all them up and then they can't breathe
they run around running into each other
and then you just Target the ones you
need with the bat and then speak to him
quietly in their emails and let them
know that it's not going to end nicely
but you're not scared that after you've
spoken to them you've left were you not
worried about repercussions no they come
to my house they come to my ass
I'll just
come out the front door and I had
um I think it was a pump house I'm not
sure if it's a pumpkin what I'm saying I
actually got arrested for these Firearms
anyway so it's not an issue
um with a pump action and I just said to
him take one more step and I'll blow
your head off mine I mean it'll come
away from my eyes what are you coming to
my eyes for and then basically once
they're all gone
never done nothing they've all gone I've
gone out on a rampage
and end up getting nicked
and arrested for trying to shoot one
I've never actually tried to shoot him
so I mean I never actually tried to
shoot them I did get for the guns they
found the guns in the back of my house
and then he got acquitted because one of
the witnesses never turned up a call to
say I'll try to shoot himself the
occasionally apart
and when you're talking about going on a
rampage and stuff do you mind me asking
you I know I know you can't talk about
everything and you might not want to but
how many actual crimes have you like as
a number have you been investigated for
oh really I couldn't but what they say
in the papers is over 24 murders 25
murders I don't know I don't really
don't because an investigation is
something that the police are in control
of so it doesn't mean anything a problem
they're investigating something so
because my name was so prominent in the
criminal fraternity anyone using my name
is an investigation I'm dragged into it
so I might not have been in it at all
it's just I'm in an investigation it's
just it's it's wording with this stuff
like I mean like
I've been on trial for 19 murders
I've been on 12 19. and when you're in
that lifestyle and you're someone that's
seen as a kind of like big figure in
that world
do does being on trial for 19 murders
back then was that like a badge of honor
almost like was it like people know you
were serious maybe I'll I'll notice me
it's not a badge of honor it's just like
right
so I mean because I don't care anymore I
said no no one does roundup in 1920
murders you know do you you the universe
won't allow your mind to survive right I
mean like you get affected mentally from
these crimes and these actions in this
lifestyle like my life has been
traumatically unbelief because of the
actions and
friendships I've kept you know because
even though you're not responsible for
pulling the trigger the fact that you're
connected to the energy the system and
the program and the and the cruiser
people do I mean you you come on you
don't tell no one you're in it you don't
mind someone's called you in it you
don't tell the police you're in it if
you know you know in it so I'll know too
much I'll know too much so it's not nice
and that's the thing about that life
it's just it's too much of a heavy
weight to carry forever Joe I mean and
people don't realize what they've got to
carry when they get in and then it
cracks you up so it's not it's there
ain't no one running around like doing
all that stuff and the ones that do end
up Mental Hospitals I mean so it's not a
life to lead like anyone who gets
involved in bad bio games up going crazy
or junkies and you can look at the
statistics yeah I like I don't know look
at all the Hitmen look at all the Hitman
statistics look at their histories look
at look at where they went up anyone
involved in gun crime look where they
end up so I mean look where they end up
they end up mad in the mental hospital
medication or dead or in prison but you
when you're in that world uh what you
say makes complete sense it's uh it's a
really interesting take on it but when
you're in that world presumably you need
to be intimidated you have to be
otherwise you get killed yeah
you like you step up the ladder right
you want to take a position so you're a
boss you're a boss and if you're not a
boss then you're a worker if you're a
worker then you're
so what do you want to be I never wanted
to be so I become a boss and no one
could be my boss so I've done things at
a level where I was my own boss and I'll
took the consequences with it and I live
with it and I'll go on with it and now
I'm making great with it so now it was I
wouldn't I wouldn't if I could go back
and do it all again I wouldn't do it
that way I'd go to university and I'd
manipulate the system that way rather
than a mini blazing system with Badness
James you're like
wow wow I just think nowadays wow now
what the was I thinking so I mean like
how could I think I was sensible
how could I think I was sensible living
that life every day leaving my house
with a firearm every day with a vest on
every day
not big bulky ones you can see on the
movies like like Finland of that t-shirt
so I mean you wear it under t-shirts so
I mean made a Kevlar uh they're these
enlightening what do you see in the
movies or movies yeah we never wore that
but so when you say you were leaving
your house with a gun and a bulletproof
vest every day was that because there
was like a real chance someone might try
to kill you every day every day from
I'll say 1997 to
2000 and
well 2014 no 2012 I got my last eight
eight osmo warnings
that's the life so vendor please have to
tell you your life is in extreme danger
and there's a 99 chance you're gonna get
killed they have to come and tell you
wow yeah and I and I'll show you I'll
send them to you so I got eight in the
last eight of them was 2012. it's eight
separate terms the police came and said
you're in extreme mortal danger I've had
loads of more in my life Wow and and is
it but like for a normal person well you
are a normal person but I mean for a
person not involved in that life the
that would be a terrifying and high high
alert situation to be in but when you're
in that life does it just become normal
or does it always ring it mate yeah
bring it
bring it bring it
bring it the [__]
bring it what what what what what what
what what
you got a problem what if I got a
problem I want to show you what my
problem is don't come and chat to me and
that was just math and that was just
math that was just math so how was that
I was instant action
um submit or action simple submit or
action then I was prepared to go to the
deaf to do it getting shot in my eye
prove that
Point Blank Range in that son Posh yeah
proves I don't care I don't care I
didn't care I said do your job you mug
do your job and I mean he shot me I said
do your job again well do you know what
you've just given me a perfect segue
into that can we actually talk about
that that event
can we talk about what led up to you
being shot in the face alola lies
cheating and learning up to that me
getting shot basically
um
apparently
the story
the story I did was this right that
basically someone took a watch of a
friend of mine right
and didn't pay for it
three weeks or a month later my friend
wrote me I'm gonna ask me if I'm gonna
pay for the watch I said hasn't he paid
you for it
why haven't you pay for the watch he
said what do you mean what's he gonna do
with you I said what's going to do with
me you cheeky
[Music]
nephew take that I'll be back in a
minute I'll give him a free 57 and I've
got Nick through as well so you get why
did you give the gun to your mate so I'm
going to pull the blues I can't kill
someone in broad daylight and build the
news so that means I'll give him the gun
but you're not worried about walking in
there unarmed I thought he'd have a
weapon a knife or bat or something but I
won't write about that I'll do remember
that yeah I mean not doing that it's not
an issue so that means I've gone down
there and then baisy I've seen his mate
had a few words with him he never spoke
any sense so then basically he asked me
to come back and bring come back to the
gym and speak to me I said no no if he's
going to get a tool because obviously
when I've sat at them his might have
realized he's not yet at all so if he's
going to get a tour I'll wait for him to
come back and use it man I ain't running
he wants to see me now and he's brave
enough we'll see him and I actually
thought he'd come out of a bat or a big
blade and I would have took a trouble or
beaten I would have value with him yeah
I mean when he pulled the gun out I just
said well do your job mate
do your job I was walking towards him
slowly and I thought grab his hand I'll
be all right but I never got close
enough he'd done me my leg and he dummy
my leg I fell over and then as I've
tried to get up he shot me again he went
through my willy shot my willy at done
my he went down my willy as well we went
into my willy down my willy and shot my
right testicle into my pants and then
I've tried to get up as I've tried to
get up he shot me again it went through
the arm off the floor through the pelvis
and at the spine and then as I've I fell
back as I was getting up he sort of
walked towards me and went bang bang and
that's when I thought I'm dead and I've
heard people walking about and I've
looked at I've seen someone I thought I
was in heaven and then he was like
I was like what's happening I said can
you get my phone I can't he run my car I
got my phone and I started making phone
calls letting people know what happened
to me so how many times you've been shot
at this point five five five times
including twice in the face yeah and you
would say can you go and get my phone
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well
what's that so I have to let my people
know like who done it no I get it but
like you've been shot five times how
were you still moving around and talking
to people and phoning people did you
like did you how did you feel at the
time could you can you remember it yeah
I was I was a bit of pain but you don't
really feel nothing it's too like you
don't feel nothing like everyone says oh
you know when you get stabbed you don't
feel it right no that's why I'm not
scared of you don't feel nothing after
you get stitched up or after you feed it
but at the time you don't feel your
Journeys who are so I don't worry about
it if I'm not I don't believe I'm gonna
die on that spot so I'll just go
steaming in that's how I believe in my
heart and in my head I've never been in
a situation where I think I'm going to
die here
I've always thought you're going to be
all right you'll be sweet just get stuck
in so I'll get stuck in so was it your
first time being shot that
oh no no no no no but that's
is can we not talk about it yeah there
was a
I mean don't say anything that's no no
what happens is
it was uh
it was a situation
there was more of an accident
than
an attack so I don't talk about it okay
fine I mean so yeah I got trouble you'd
experienced it before yeah so you sort
of knew what was happening okay and and
then so you see at that point so you'd
been shot in the eye hadn't you so at
that point did you realize you were
blind no I just went numb it just all
went numb but yeah and I could still see
those you could yeah
so then you who did you call when you
got your phone
well you go eventually okay fine I'll
I'll rephrase it eventually you called
the ambulance didn't you yeah yeah yeah
after that no I run I run I run the
ambulance and they didn't believe me
right because you've got a call it's
called helicopter Sagittarius okay are
you gonna sign up to a pedal
um private medical so when I've rung
them and told them what happened they
hung up on me and I had to wait for the
police to turn up for the police to ring
the ambulance so at this point are you
not just where are you again did you say
you're in a gym outside of no I was
outside Sully's Bar Sully's Diner in
Paul bunus so you're just on the street
yeah so he shot you in Broad day outside
all the restaurants about 90 or 80 80s
or 90 Witnesses you've all done to me
bare face broad daylight do you think
that's because he was scared I don't
know you have runs I don't know why he
done that yeah I mean but me positive
he's only a three grand watch right
right so
after growing learning and developing
I've actually realized it was for a
greater purpose but that's another story
for another time yeah okay so you so
you're lying there uh the the the
ambulance
eventually turn up and they find you
shot five times twice in the face
presumably lost quite a lot of blood you
know what I'll never bludgeon on what
imagine that my friend will actually got
punctured right I got putting pot
punched in three places and I never bled
so okay so they turn up you're you're
there and then like do you remember the
next period of time is it being taken
yeah I remember telling the doctor keep
the leg I don't give up how much it cost
because when when when when when he shot
me and I've collapsed yeah because the
the FEMA had been shattered into so many
pieces right so it just squashed so my
leg just looked deformed and I'm lying
on the floor my leg looked deformed so
when I was in the hospital I just said
to the doctor a doctor
I've got to keep my leg I don't care how
much it costs it doesn't matter keep my
leg do whatever you got to do and then I
woke up with 16 pins and the big plates
a platinum plate from the whole the
plate is the whole size of my femur
every 16 pins in it I woke up with
nothing
and so you wake up and like obviously I
know you'll tell me if there's any stuff
that you can't answer but like
what what happened to the guy that shot
you he went and handed himself in right
right so I got shot right and then
basically well done when I first went to
do a hospital
because I was paranoid that they might
come to the hospital to finish the
agenda right so what I've done is I've
told everybody that I was dead I was
dying I'd septicemia so I mean because I
wanted to get better I wanted my people
around me in the hospital so for the
first two weeks everyone thought I was
dying I sent people with information
I've owned a real small circle of
friends that I have and said I'm good
I'm good I'm good I'm good we were
partying in the hospital we were I was
tired the very first time because I woke
up buzzing that I was alive yeah so I
was still active I was still good
commune crime so I was still doing
things I still had my team around me so
they was coming up I was making money I
was doing things I was partying I was
I was puffing I was puffing I was
drinking I was having a laugh I was
having a joke and then I was telling
everybody I'd accept to see him it looks
like I'm gonna die looks like I'm gonna
die I was gonna die and then basically I
had to wait for the police
to leave so I had to tell the police
they can't protect me no more I need
them to go so then when they've gone
I've got a couple of bits and pieces in
the hotel in the hospital to make sure
I'm protected and um and that was it
once I've let everybody know I'm fine
and I'm bouncing back and I'm going to
be back on road they went and handed
themselves into the police station with
a prepared statement that said that I am
a Hitman I am a Hitman from London yeah
give Mark hashman a watch right and then
because he couldn't pay for it I got
paid to kill him this is the statement I
made to the base they said to the police
I made a statement they they made a
statement to the police that I was a
hitman paid to come and collect the
money for the watch and I'll come to
shoot him and when I started shooting
him he grabbed the gun and it went off
five times accidentally and that's what
got me shot that was their statement
prepared statement facts right so then
basically they come and asked me what
happened I said look I don't know who it
was that shot me I've never seen him
before in my life I said what I can tell
you is this I'm scared of no man but God
and the deep blue sea and that is it and
the only reason I'm not making the
statement is because I'm a criminal in
England and my whole family will disown
me if I make a statement and on that
purpose I'm not making a statement
so that was the statement I made to the
police so was anyone ever convicted of
shooting yeah yeah eight years okay
you've got eight years okay
I want to join up with a man and do a
course on forgiveness okay worth it I
got no problem with him if it weren't
for him I wouldn't be where I'm today
we'll even be seeing it yeah I'm all I'd
be sitting in the prison cell or even
dead yeah I mean so I actually
appreciate what he's done because no one
else had the [__] until he done it to
do it so I mean that's amazing that
you've come that that far along that
path but when you're saying that when
you woke up like you it sounds like you
were like you say you were buzzing in
the hospital but were you not I mean
there'd been some severe physical injury
as soon as I wiggle my toes yeah I knew
I was walking again okay simple even
though your your eyes
Okay so I brought my leg every day for
18 months because they told me I can't
do nothing and you gotta do drugs what
they tell me to take all this stuff so
that's when I've become a vegan because
I had to find out all the stuff that
make my bones grow again and I found out
that dairy products are full of poison
and they give you no calcium okay so now
stop taking calcium through milk and
dairy products and I started looking for
vitamin B1 6 and 12. I mean in all the
vitamins I started looking for in all
the foods and I found out all the foods
is in the greens and The Roots and the
berries and and then I've just stopped
eating all normal food and did they
think you wouldn't walk again yeah they
told you you wouldn't yeah so I'll never
ever walk again and I did and then they
said I'll never ever get 90 degree I'll
never be able to get more than a 90
degree Bend in my leg right look
yeah that's what they said and they said
watch
like what
foreign
[Music]
for most people I think what you've just
described and being shot would have been
a trigger to potentially change things
but it sounded like that wasn't the case
for you so what was it what was the
turning point for you when you changed
if I'm being honest is mine in the right
place
yes
I'm basically
it was a combination of
events
Baisley so I got arrested in 2012 for
murders and I got extradited from Spain
to phase 12. they reduce the original
offenses from murder to a system and
defender in the Dow kriegen trial and
then basically when I got back to
England
eventually I thought I was going to be
kind of way
for a long time and then when I see the
evidence I knew I'd been fitted up I
mean basically I fought the case and
whilst I was on remand
a couple of people got arrested and this
was the first sort of ripple effect so a
couple of people have been nicked and
they've been nicked with a couple of
tons of products and basically when I
see them in strange ways they told me
they was getting six years which was
unheard of from my generation it started
at 15 years and upwards right with a ton
of enemy right so when he said that I
was like how are you gonna do that he
said well I've made a deal already
obviously my back went up straight I was
like what do you mean you made a deal
what are you talking about he said well
early indication
so I said what are you talking about he
said early indication I said what are
you talking about he said well early in
the case I said mate mate because at
that time I was still a criminal right
so I'm thinking he's with a snitch so
I'm saying bruh you need to tell me what
do you mean early indication you're
getting a six how how how I don't get it
well now if you let the police now in
the police station that you're going to
please yui you get 50 off I'm
only a minor role so my maximum is 12
years and I've been guaranteed six
I was like shut up he's like yeah
straight on the phone to myself I was
saying is this right it's like yeah
that was the first point of my wow do
you know what imagine if they nicked
someone
and offer them no bud
what would I do for that so they're
getting for 50 off their sentence they
get
[Music]
rather than do rather that why don't you
just give us a name we'll let you out
let us know what's going on we'll let
you out
how many people who are not going to
take that deal
only two percent so I'm dealing with 98
of people that are going to throw me
under a bus when I'm I moved to another
country to be safe
doing the business right now what I've
realized at that point is everybody I
work with here can throw me under the
bus there so there's no point in being
there so there's no point in being in it
so I started questioning wow what am I
gonna do
basically
I decided to
do a little bit of
bits and Bobs solo speak and then one of
the young kids
that was working for me run a bill up to
200 Grand now
bearing in mind they got the product at
a price where they can double their
profit then there was no need to get in
debt so how does someone like that get
in debt what does that mean because
basically I was Nick for four murders so
in their head I weren't coming home
oh so what he'd been using he's been
taken taken taken taken taken so when I
got out and I've seen because obviously
you do your figures I was right I've
seen my figures I was like how the [__]
is he on that much right how
I wanted to get him out so I'm gonna put
The Feelers out and the messages are and
got the kid lined up to get him done
and then I find that he's from my area
so I only said to shoot him in his legs
and I found out he's my son's friend
and I thought wow so then basically I
fall I'll teach them a lesson still and
I thought the ripples affected me
teasing the lesson the effects of my son
the first month my extended family you
know like and it's just never-ending
problems so if I'd do anything to this
kid and he dies or he ends up disabled
then my son my cousins my nephews my
aunt he's their life ruined so I thought
wow I'm not going to do that so well
done I got the kid I said to him look I
want to sell your debt to someone else
who are more likely kill you so you can
either come off the road today because I
can't do this no more that was the day
I'll come off the road in 2014 I'll just
come up with a Criminal anything
criminally
motivated or anything that uses a young
kid to go to prison or risk his life I
wouldn't do it no more and that's what I
chose to do in 2014 to what you said to
that guy
if you come off the debt's written off
but if you want to keep doing it
and they come off the road and he's
become a real good person he's got a
good industry he's in the music world
and he's got a couple of really decent
heists there's actually because you
mentioned this on a previous video we
did and there was a lot of comments of
people on the video who think they know
who that guy was I don't know are we
allowed am I allowed to take you on
Julia no more Charlie sloth
no okay Charlie's love is someone that
I've
I've known a very long time and right
Charlie's out of his own mouth he said
he wouldn't be where he is today if he
wasn't for me getting involved in a
certain stage of his life um Charlie's a
very good friend like a family member
and he's very close with my closest
family member so the closest person to
me in my family is my cousin Anthony and
Charlie's the best mate in has been for
the last three so that's the connection
between you and I see Charlie's Family
Annie's disguisance huh Sorry Charlie
everyone knows you're a scarcity
so the so with with that did you at the
point at that point in time did your son
know that the danger that his friend was
in from you or was it all separated I
didn't even know no I didn't know my son
didn't know what I'd done yeah my family
didn't know what I'd done yeah they just
knew I was a criminal yeah and there are
shot people and hurt people and I was
investigating my mouth my son knew I was
when I got Nick for murders he didn't
speak to me for a little while because
he he was a he he got brought up as a
Catholic so when I got meet
he refused to space me
every appearance just pays me for three
years when I was in prison he wouldn't
speak to me because I was a murderer
he wouldn't speak to me because he said
I was a murderer and he wouldn't speak
to me or throughout my whole sentence
and then towards the end of the
sentences that are coming around
and then I've tried to build it but me
and him just all those speeds today
you always want the best for your kids
and I always wanted my son to be a
better version of me however he doesn't
see that he doesn't see what I want for
him he thinks I just want him to be me
and he isn't the case I wanted to be a
much better version of me that lives a
much better life than me in a much
better way however he doesn't see that
and he doesn't understand that so we
still have conflict that will overcome a
pitch
we'll get through that we'll go through
that because I'm his dad and I'll never
give up
that's the sad thing about him he knows
I'll never give up so he might be uh he
might not understand what I've done what
I've done he might not appreciate why
I've been where I've been but when he
has kids and he grows up he might see
things from a different perspective
and you when you came like as you say
you came off the road you made that
decision everything stopped from that
day what were you thinking you do with
your life after that well I had a friend
that had done it
and he used to work with a guy called
Bobby Cummins Uncle Bobby coming yeah so
my bad Uncle Bobby coming so basically
my friend turned his life around with
Bobby Cummins and I thought if he can do
it I can do it so well I'll go out and
chill whilst I was in jail I'll raise
that to my pal and I said look can you
help us out I'm gonna do this when I
come out I want to get involved in what
you're doing is there any room he said
of course if you're genuine I said mate
no I'm fed up but it's a hardly bothered
she said if your outfit then we'll do it
we'll say all that so I started working
with a company called the nor initiative
when I got her and um basically it just
went from strength to strength mate and
I started speaking in the London School
of Economics or the London School of
entrepreneurs some London scores
something over London Bridge and um
amen
members of parliament members of the
police I spoke at and they they embraced
me and then they invite me to another
event another event another event
another event the next thing change
English reach out to me and I'm just and
they just went from there and I've just
been non-stops ever since
and it's just about making the answers
understand now
said I don't have to live that life it
ain't worth it for a minute for a second
for
today I'm worth it it's not worth it
you're better off going to school you
run off spending a couple of years
getting a qualification in something and
building a business yeah I mean like
I'll say work and build a business build
businesses create work uh that's where
I'm at creating so I'm in that Journey
now I'm not working for no one but I
will create businesses for people to
work for and do you
do you think if someone like yourself
had spoken to you as a young person it
could have made a positive impact and
changed the path
[Applause]
I wish I had someone like me which I
mean I wish I had one of the old not to
tell me and I always I've only enough
I had someone edgy top and I bless you
mate like he's dead now arrested
yourself my Ellie Tobin used to beat me
you know and he said tell me what are
you doing you mug don't be a mug you're
wasting your life and I just figured
with you I used to be used
I don't think those videos shut up
obviously I'm getting money you're an
idiot you ain't got a clue and when he
died it broke my heart you know because
I couldn't thank him for trying to keep
me away from the
this is
that's the reality of that life if you
want to be bad enough and brave enough
to be honest about it then come on this
platform and talk about it and you'll
see who's being real because if they
can't be real with their emotions then
what's the point and when you look back
now at your life like which is obviously
it is an extraordinary life it's so
different to so many people's lives when
you look back like what do you think is
something you've learned as a person now
at this point
through your experiences what have they
taught you
be humble
just to be humble and harmonious
and don't be angry there's no need for
anger there's just no need for anger
anger is a suggestion and you can
respond to where you don't need to react
so I'm working with and I'll give
Professor Steve p as his props here the
chin Paradox and I'll talk about it all
the time I couldn't have done it without
that book and I've reached out to them
so many times to create a similar book
for people like me from certain
environments so they can understand it
better because your voice whines people
up from my world and we needed them for
voice that's hard to think about Dr
Steve Peters but if you do a different
advice you might get a better result
because the people that need that book
people like me in abundance that need
that what is it what does that book tell
you about the chimp Paradox is the Mind
management tool okay uh it's amazing for
since reading that book I'm where I am
today right I wouldn't be here today you
weren't for that book and Daniel came
down I know he's got his own little
he's that man told me how to be a man
and how to be legit and how to be
straight and how to be correct and
something coming from something that's
perceived to be so toxic is unbelievable
so
I'm spawned from nothing but trauma and
more positive outlook and outcome in
life now I believe will change certain
things within our society you know and
that's why I believe I was born to Luna
because I'm people that I you know he
thinks he's his Visa but I just I don't
people say how do you do it I don't know
I really don't know
I don't know how I've done it I don't
know I don't know how I never got scared
I don't know how I never got frightened
I don't know I just wasn't do I mean so
I know the universe has done things with
me because I've never felt the pain like
it don't hurt nothing hurts the way I
don't get up in the morning carry on
that yeah it's a little bit that's a
little bit even my leg he got shot and I
walked about I got about two months
after I got shot I was about collecting
money again I was out doing business so
I mean with a messed up leg so pain
wasn't a thing that stopped me doing
anything but pain isn't one thing that's
driving me towards change so I mean the
change that I need isn't for myself
which I mean is for
a part of society that's lost because of
her son mindset and programming and they
can change that and I believe I'm going
to be the driving force in that you know
and if I get if I'm the Pied Piper who's
creating new businesses sustainable
income and sustainable communities then
I've done a great job so that's what I'm
destined to be doing for the next couple
of years well what I've got to say is
that you're clearly someone that has
like an amazingly strong will an amazing
strong drive and like for me personally
I'm really really pleased that your
focus is on those things now because I
think I mean you seem like someone that
once you set your mind to something
whether it's walking again not changing
your business it gets done so yeah I'm
really grateful that you're on the side
of the universe now creating these
opportunities and trying to you know
break the cycle of what you were sadly
born into well look it's been brilliant
having you in really enjoyed talking to
you really inspirational guy and wish
you all the best thank you very much
sometimes
again they've gone down there to tell
these Lads to go on because they were
terrorizing customers waiting for trains
in there and they'd switch them beat
them up pretty bad pretty bad right
cowardly thing to do they weren't that
they didn't know what they were doing
they were just thugs